You can figure out how many t-tests we need by brute force. We would need one
between A and B, A and C, A and D, B and C, et cetera. Then, you see that we
need six t-tests. As you can see, the number of t-tests we would have to do
does not equal the number of samples we want to compare. We have to do even
more t-tests. You don't have to know this but the way to figure out how many
t-tests we would have to do with n samples, is found be choosing 2 out of n.
This is the symbolic notation for that, which is equal to n factorial divided
by two factorial, since 2 is here, times n minus two factorial. So, for example
if we want to compare 10 samples, the number of t test we would do is 10
factorial divided by 2 factorial, times 8 factorial. Remember that factorial
means 10 times 9 times 8 times 7, et cetera, all the way to one, divided by 2
times 1, for 2 factorial, times 8 factorial. These parts cancel out and we're
left with 10 times 9 divided by 2, which is 45. We would have to do 45 t-tests
just to compare 10 samples. We want something a lot simpler.